any outdoor plans with mom on sunday oh
ouch you're going to be a little rough
so if you want to take mom hiking or you
want to take her out maybe for some
pickleball or anything outdoors it is
going to be on the windy side we still
have some high clouds around this
morning but they're shifting out valley
temperatures mostly upper 60s on the
west side low 70s just about everywhere
else 68 up at aliante 64 out at red rock
today would be a good day to get out
hiking the afternoon will probably bring
us some southwest breezes we've got near
70 in boulder city 60 at indian springs
67 in peru and mesquite 72 in laughlin
right now and 30s up there in ely
a little cool up there well death valley
hit 103 for a high yesterday probably up
more like 105 today this will probably
be our warmest day of the week but then
this system off the pacific northwest
coast will eventually
get into our area or at least much
closer to us by sunday and that's going
to bring the roughest winds of the
weekend so high clouds shifting out wind
advisories have been issued for saturday
for areas along the colorado river
valley out to lake mead northwest
arizona and southeast california so any
driving that you may be doing saturday
in those areas or if you're just going
to have fun on the river or whatever
know there's going to be rougher winds
over 40 miles an hour expected fire
weather warnings for all areas of
southern nevada saturday and sunday with
dry gusty conditions today we could see
25 mile an hour winds up on the mountain
beautiful though it's 70 degrees now the
lake is going to get dicey out there
with the water and that water can get
choppy 15 to 25 mile an hour winds today
but we're talking sustained winds maybe
up to 30 plus for saturday and gusts
over 40 so that water is going to be
very very unpredictable
with in choppy waves 97 today and still
in the mid 90s tomorrow at lake mead
please wear your life jackets life vests
for everybody in the boat and on the
shoreline if you're going to be swimming
96 for the valley and mother's day will
cool down a little bit 84
but check out those wind speeds over 40
miles an hour expected sunday afternoon
so mom oh just say it with roses i'm
sorry mom we were supposed to eat on the
patio but we're gonna have to move
inside look at the beautiful 70s though
after sunday for monday tuesday
wednesday a beautiful spring days next
week